the league has jurisdiction over the
things that happen on game days the
teams have jurisdiction over the things
that players and non-players may do
while off duty and we spent a lot of
time talking about the negotiations
between the league and the union that
resulted in a list of things
that players can't do when they're away
from
work and that prompted the criticism of
the incident that occurred on monday
night when a bunch of raider players
went to an event in an indoor setting
where
there were no masks in sight it was
stupid the optics were poor the
decisions were poor everything about it
was poor
three weeks into the season with the
quarterback of the team there the one
person in the locker room who should
know better the guy who's got an
incentive to the tune of over 1.1
million a week
in the event that games are canceled
because remember the agreement was
the players get paid based on the games
that are played
car is going to lose more money than
anyone else on that team if the raiders
have an outbreak that keeps them from
playing games
here is john gruden from yesterday with
his thoughts
on the unfortunate videos that you're
watching now that emerged on tuesday of
players in a place where they shouldn't
have been on monday night
let me say this we've done a good job
we've done an excellent job last night
it was addressed with our players they
walked in with their mass on there was
an event
sometimes you go to a restaurant you
take your mask off
they're aware of their mistake but we've
done an excellent job
using our mass and taking proper care of
each other and everybody
i'm really proud of our players and by
the way that was a great cause no one's
talked about he raised over three
hundred thousand dollars for a great
great cause i appreciate our players
being there in support of him
but you're right they may have let their
dauber down a little bit by taking their
mask off
during the event but it's been addressed
and
that's the best i can tell you
all right three things real quickly
number one taking the masks off was
stupid in and of itself
because number two they shouldn't have
even been there
that's the thing that your guy john
gruden didn't address it violates local
ordinances right there's too many people
in a confined space it doesn't matter if
you have your mask on or not you
shouldn't have been there
and here's number three because this is
the justification we're going to hear it
coming up from
derek carr as well that well it was a
great cause well you know what folks in
a pandemic
there are plenty of great causes that
can't have fundraising events you can't
just say well we're going to ignore the
rules of the pandemic because it's for a
good cause
good cause bad cause i mean we're trying
to keep businesses open
that's a good cause we can't the
businesses have to be closed
in certain jurisdictions because of the
outbreak so don't give me this
false notion that well it was a great
cause and let's not lose sight of that
look
other charities have to find other ways
to raise money in a pandemic
you don't just say well it's a good
cause so we're going to do something
stupid that's going to potentially get
people dead is it a great
cause if somebody ends up leaving there
with coven 19 and causes somebody to die
somewhere else in that exactly right is
that 300 000
worth somebody's life i don't know i
mean life seems to be going for a very
low price here in this country right now
so
maybe it is i don't know but yeah i mean
that's where it's a little
listen like we said from the start and
i've always said this and you know this
players don't give a damn about covet
19. they're young they're healthy this
is just more
more of you know here's more evidence to
show that
now they they as a raider i know they
love their quarterback derek carr
from everything i've ever heard from the
start of training camp and things like
that
like the offense is very close together
they're very supportive of each other it
sounds like they were there as almost a
full unit
at that thing but you know again like
what you're saying
first off it's state and local ordinance
it's
a bad look for leadership in our country
right now
just where we are and then of course
it's risky
not just for for the whole nfl that's
where it's just a little careless i mean
that that's really what it is
and it's an iq test a little bit to go
to a place like that
and think oh i'll get away with this and
nobody will ever find out to me that's
where i just
i can't believe that and and my the
other thing i just don't understand too
because and i need you to explain this
to me
so they can't find these like so you can
find a coach a hundred thousand dollars
for having a mask
down on the sideline in one of the
safest environments in our world right
now
but they can't find players for going
out to an event like that that's illegal
and doing things like that right now
that's what's what's the deal with that
mike
the league can't yeah the teams can
but the team's not required to do it for
players the team is required to do it
for non-players wow the team's not
required to do it for players so
when your star quarterback's there or
the guy that you're paying like a star
quarterback is there
what are you going to do you're going to
suspend him no you're going to hurt your
own interest see
i think these rules were all put in
place to to with the idea of the guys at
the bottom of the roster in mind
because they just assumed that the guys
who were making the most money who were
in the most high profile positions
wouldn't do something that stupid and
speaking of guys doing something stupid
and
chris we've had a long first segment
here and we've got a long clip of derek
carr i'm going to give you the emperor
privilege remember how they used to do
like in gladiator oh right i'm going to
let you do the up or down
you give me the up or down on whether or
not we listen to derek carl oh
because i mean i'm inclined not to
listen to the guy you tell me
i'm giving are we gonna do a thumbs up
yeah i'm going thumbs up he lives
okay he lives all right yup this is the
only context in which you'll ever hear
from derek carr on this program because
he'll never come on and by the way he'll
never be invited here's derek carr two
minutes damn
i feel like one we've done a a fantastic
job around here and i hate i hate
that a few moments without our mass on
led to a story about our team and all
this kind of stuff and
especially after you know the fines that
were
you know brought on a few a couple weeks
ago and so we felt terrible about that
we addressed it we talked with coach and
we talked with our trainers
um you know about about what what really
went down and
um and all that kind of stuff but at the
end of the day we were there
i mean shoot guys i i have to have you
know
dinners and dates with my wife at my
house you know i haven't taken her out
to eat all season
you know and that's a lot of kids
running around my house i think she's
ready
for a date and so we've been we've been
doing our very best and we had a few
moments where we
we slipped up took the mass off uh so
people could see our face and things
like that
um we signed waivers hand sanitizer like
crazy
all this kind of stuff we tried our best
even at the event uh with everything
and we weren't perfect but we were
trying our best we weren't trying to be
careless or reckless
um but at the same time uh darren waller
had an event
uh for something that meant a lot to him
and they raised so much money
that you won't even you only begin to
imagine how much money they raise to
to help other people that struggle with
addiction to get them in the right
places and things like that
my hope and my prayer is that a few
moments of us messing up
a few minutes here where we were seen on
camera
not in the private room in the separate
room for an hour you know and things
like that
i hope i hope that we don't lose what
was really going on there because darren
had a great
a great idea he had a great plan he
wants to help people
and i hope that we can just more so move
the conversation that way again we've
addressed it in-house we
we admit you know we we should have kept
the mask on even if
you know we are you know coming and
they're introducing us and things like
that
uh but but at the end of the day i hope
that the story is more about what darren
was able to accomplish and uh and all
those kind of things so
okay um where are the videos and the
photos of these guys with their masks on
why is it this strange coincidence that
the only thing that we saw
are there videos out there of derek carr
with his mask on they act like they just
had this momentary lapse
what a coincidence that that's the only
point where someone was filming them
i and here's the thing what do we talk
about when you've got your mask on and
you take it off for a little bit you
still see it i don't see a mask on
the car nobody has a mask on anybody in
the crowd there's nobody there that has
a mascot
that's you know so i you know it again
it's just careless it's just you know to
me that's where it is it's careless
you're jeopardizing things for your team
the league other people that work around
the league
tv people all of it that's where it's
just a little selfish to me
i know derek carr is a good person i
know that i really do
i mean i've been around him a few times
i'm not saying he's a cop
villain i know i'm just doing it i'm
just saying i know exactly right
their hearts in the right place but you
know they they let their heart lead them
sometimes as football players who can be
like
you know myself included a big dumb
animal at times that's the way football
players are
oh okay friend you got to do something
i'll be there to support your friend i
play football with you that's how we
think sometimes
and this is one of those times where you
can't go with your heart
in that way you got to use your brain a
little bit more because of what's going
on in the world and of course now
they're talking about and having to deal
with it
and uh you know that that's the issue
and let's end it on this point because
the best evidence that the brain wasn't
properly functioning inside the cranium
of derek carr is this
the idea that we signed waivers makes it
okay
well the waiver isn't going to protect
you from getting the
virus and if nothing else that moment
where
you had to put pen to paper to sign away
your legal rights
that was your last chance to realize you
know what
i probably shouldn't be here
this probably is something i shouldn't
be doing if i'm engaging in activities
that require the person hosting the
activity to force me to sign a waiver
this probably falls in the category of
things that coach told us we shouldn't
be
doing if we want to play the full
football season and again
this guy's got over 1.1 million riding
on each game that's played
they have an outbreak they miss a game
they don't play
16 games he doesn't get 1.1 million
dollars folks and i don't
care about anything he said to justify
it
it's stupid it's selfish and i thought
that kind of behavior
was going to be coming from the guys on
the bottom of the roster
who just got into the league not the
quarterback and if you don't take action
what's the message chris to the rest of
the locker room
what's the message to the other 31 teams
there's no concept we're going to let
you have at least one
mistake so you got that going for you
we'll worry about the second mistake
when it happens
yeah we're going to look the other way
on the first mistake no that's why i'm
surprised i'm you know i'm surprised
about how this was laid out you know
just what you explained to me earlier
that the team is really in charge here
and the nfl has no
you know uh has no jurisdiction over
this matter when it comes to that that
was that's very surprising to me in this
where where
we know it's about guys being
self-disciplined that's what it's all
about this year
and that's part of like winning the
championship is you're going to have to
be self-disciplined on and off the field
all year long if you want to be there at
the end
and we're seeing some teams where oh oh
a few cracks here and there
what's that mean i don't know we got a
long season left and this week we just
got done with three weeks and we got one
team that's got an outbreak and another
team that already seems to have
let their guard down and think life's
fine and we're going to go back to
normal
it's a tuesday morning it felt like it
was all in on issue and we're going to
sail right through all 17 weeks and
in the 48 hours since then it's like
well you know what this really is
uh a flip of the coin may be at best as
to whether or not there's going to be an
interruption of the schedule
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports